what I want to argue but I ended up
arguing in some work I've done on
Burning Man and Google is that the mode
of gathering that we see in the desert
here is a kind of emblem of new modes of
manufacturing that are emerging across
the tech industry and migrating from the
tech industry into other spaces let me
take it a little bit slowly in the 19th
century Max Weber talked about the
Protestant ethic and how its shaped
industrial production I want to argue
that Burning Man is too contemporary new
media production what the Protestant
church was - industrial production in
the 19th century if you lived in
Pittsburgh in the 19th century you would
go to church with your other factory
mates your steel mill mates the
executives would sit up front middle
management would be right behind them
and you the workers would be in the way
back here at Burning Man if you've if
you've been away a little quick check
how many have actually been to the playa
I love this room thank you that's great
ok so if you've been to the ply it you
know that this is a space of kind of
radical individuality and radical
collaboration people go to the playa
they buy a ticket they leave their money
off sensibly mostly behind the drive out
and they work on art projects together
they work collaboratively and when they
get out there they're extraordinarily
visible to one another they can see one
another they can make art it's a weirdly
individuated and collective place it's a
place where you can build new social
networks and new technological goods at
the same time it is in many ways I would
argue a model of a project-based
technologic technology centered economy
but it's done in a spiritual idiom it's
a place to practice the deepest values
on which the engineering culture of
Google depends and it's partly for that
reason that things like whole Earth
emblems of whole earth ideology recur in
a place like Facebook which is otherwise
a company devoted to profiting from mass
surveillance
[Music]
you